In the real world, it's entirely possible that language influences thought,
and it may be that some things are easier in 1 language than another.
In the world of computing, the languages that we are considering,
like Python and JavaScript, are ultimately equally expressive in a strong formal sense.
However, we often still think that some things are easier--
that is, maybe they take you a little less time to write or they're a little easier to read,
they feel a little more natural--in 1 language than another.
You may just prefer writing code in Python to writing code in JavaScript
even though ultimately you could say all of the same things in JavaScript.
One may feel a little easier to you even though the end results would be the same.
So I assert that interpreting or translating between 2 systems of meaning
is actually a very deep concept.
And 1 interesting downside for us is that simulating a program,
interpreting it, translating it often requires running it.
Let's see how that plays out.
Here I've written a simple Python program,
the sort that we might want to translate or interpret into JavaScript and then back again,
and what I'd like to know is, what does it do? Maybe it prints 0.
I've listed a few options.
I want you to think about this program in your head
and tell me, what will happen if I run it?
Check all that apply, bearing in mind that I am trying to trip you up.